buonasera a tutti
macabra di caiazzo e
sono qui per presentarvi un prototipo
realizzato questo dispositivo si chiama
andy end è una mano robotica che ho
sviluppato a scuola sono infatti da poco
diplomato all'istituto tecnico and the
end nasce tre banchi di scuola come
essenzialmente un gioco inizialmente
come lo accendo ve la faccio vedere come
un gioco come un oggetto bello da vedere
e divertente anche da utilizzare ma
andando avanti con le mie ricerche ho
capito le ricerche necessarie per
sviluppare questo dispositivo
ho capito che sarebbe potuto essere
qualcosa di molto di più è in grado
infatti di copiare quasi fedelmente i
movimenti di un vero alto come potete
vedere adesso questo 4 questo qua è
soltanto un prototipo e quindi non non
fa tutte quante le funzioni della
versione finale ovviamente ma in grado
adesso di copiare i movimenti delle
singole dita è stato potrebbe anche di
scuola ma ha avuto dei risvolti molto
importanti ha partecipato alla rom cup
2015 è anche un evento all'expo come
funziona
colui che lo usa a questo quanto di
cinque sensori
dopodiché la circuteria via radio
trasmetterà tutte le informazioni al
ricevitore
chel elaborerà e farà muovere la mano
permettendo un movimento indipendente
delle cinque dita qui possiamo vedere
negli sviluppi
che ci sono stati dei banchi di scuola e
i vari steps di costruzione del
dispositivo
abbiamo poi io e il mio team abbiamo
pensato di utilizzarla per quanto di più
di più serio ovvero equipaggiarla sotto
un vero alto che magari con per
qualsiasi problema per esempio motorio
un problema di forza poteva usare andy
end per prendere qualcosa in questa cosa
possiamo dire abbiamo preso degli
oggetti come un ombrello e una busta e
non stavo usando nessun tipo di forza
sulle sulle dita e andy and faceva tutto
il resto utilizzando la forza alla
precisione e la stabilità dei motori
successivamente sono stati dei
consequenziali sviluppi ed è passato da
una versione via cavo a una versione
wireless ovvero senza fili questo
permette una comunicazione a distanza e
a seconda ovviamente del della portata
che noi abbiamo della potenza dei nostri
trasmettitori e ricevitori possiamo
arrivare sia a 20 centimetri che anche
dall'altra parte del mondo
essenzialmente come una semplice
chiamata noi col telefono possiamo
chiamare tranquillamente un nostro amico
che sta dall altra parte del mondo e con
lo stesso principio possiamo comandare
questo alto robotico un importante dei
crociati che voglio parlare di questa
sera è il 3d printing ovvero la stampa
3d possiamo vedere dalle foto che la
parte superiore tutta quanta il tutto il
palmo le dita e le cartilagini della
mano sono talmente stampata in 3d con
della plastica verde a stampa per dio un
processo totalmente rivoluzionario che
sta modificando la produzione in serie
di tool della maggior parte degli
oggetti che vengono tutti oggi è un
processo ancora purtroppo poco
sconosciuto ma che grazie alla
potenzialità dell'open source e con open
source intendo sia open hardware che
open software si sta diffondendo a
macchia d'olio una stampante 3d che
cos'è è un semplice macchinario capace
di creare dei soliti oggetti in 3d
ovvero dei degli oggetti fisici e non
semplice un immagine stampata su un
foglio
lavora essenzialmente con una stampante
normale o immaginate una stampante
normale a un foglio e una testina e
grazie al movimento combinato di
entrambi si può riprodurre un'immagine e
quindi spandendo i colori della testina
dell'inchiostro stesso principio basta
applicare una terza dimensione ovvero
sollevando la testina strato dopo strato
e modificando ovviamente l'immagine da
stampare
in questo modo possiamo vedere che è
possibile creare degli oggetti molto
complessi come quello in foto o come per
esempio alcuni piccoli oggetti che ho
portato per per esempio queste forme
sono dei semplici forme matematiche dei
dei modelli matematici che però
sarebbero stati impossibili da
ricostruire con un
un altro macchinario ovvero una fresa
computerizzata o tantomeno di produrli a
mano per questo la stampa 3d è un
processo veramente innovativo efficace
per produrre molti tipi di oggetti
complicati la stampa 3d come ho detto
funziona utilizzando una tecnologia
simile a quello della stampa normale
movendo l'estrusore che quello che
possiamo vedere in alto a destra
una punta a calda un estrusore caldo che
scioglie la plastica classico siamo
dello meglio in azione
c'è un filamento di classi ha chiamato
quello più comune per los per la stampa
è chiamato pla ovvero acido polilattico
è una plastica derivata biodegradabile
atossica deriva da mais e grano e le
altre cose simili viene sciolta questo
filamento che di plastica a fondo viene
sciolto dalle strutture a una
temperatura circa 250 gradi e viene poi
spalmato effettivamente spalmato sul
piatto di stampa e possiamo vedere con
uno zoom su questa immagine a sinistra i
vari strati che la stampa va costi che
la stampante va a creare
infatti dopo strato dopo strato mostrato
il pezzo cresce e quindi alla fine possa
avere un oggetto solido
ovviamente in base al materiale che
stiamo utilizzando avremo una resistenza
più o meno maggiore materiale più comune
è un pla ovvero questa prassi ma di cui
stava parlando altri tipi di plastiche
sono la biesse che però è tossico però è
più più esistente allo sforzo meccanico
ma con noi filamenti di ultima
generazione quali nylon legno ceramica
ma anche i materiali magnetici e ferrosi
è possibile creare dei veri oggetti in
ferro pronti per l'utilizzo
ovviamente ci sono vari tipi di
stampanti come anche stampante 3d come
anche diverse tecnologie di stampa 2d
sono le stampanti alla search sono le
stampanti a inchiostro come anche qui ci
sono stampanti
a tecnologia fm ovvero fuse posting
modeling ovvero modellazione di oggetti
attraverso la deposizione di di plastica
sciolta ma anche delle stampanti laser
ovvero viene depositata con strati
nell'ordine del micron ovvero circa il
micron sarebbe un millesimo di
millimetro quindi strati molto piccoli
un'altra risoluzione queste stampanti
stendono una polvere di metallo che
proviene attraverso un laser
computerizzato sciolta il termine
tecnico sarebbe sinterizzato e quindi
sivia ottenere un pezzo solito di
metallo pronto all'uso
i risultati sono strabilianti e possiamo
vedere qui per esempio a destra delle
forme geometriche veramente impossibile
realizzare con qualsiasi altra
tecnologia che esclusa ovviamente alla
stampa 3d
al centro c'è un piccola un piccolo
ragno sapesse potenti che ho fatto con
la stampante che ho a casa e poi a
destra altri esempi di oggetti che
comunque oltre al semplice design
possono coprire le funzioni veramente
utili come per esempio che stanno
dicendo la mano
stampato in 3d pensavamo della stampa 3d
non avrei mai potuto costruire la andy
end tutto parte da un virtual model
usando un caso ad esempio che conoscete
rhino oppure
autocad questi software di modellazione
3d servono a creare dei veri oggetti in
3d solidi che poi vengono passati
attraverso vari step di lavorazione del
software per creare un codice puramente
numerico che poi la stampante è come se
lo mangia se lo digerisse e facendo
muovere sulle tre assi l'estrusore e
facendolo crescere sulla terza se perché
oggetto in 3d appunto che il risultato
finale è che possiamo vedere le varie
fasi inizialmente c'è l'oggetto creato
3d
poi c'è una seconda lavorazione software
per ricavare i vari strati che poi la
stampante andrò ad eseguire e per ultimo
l'oggetto fisico realizzato che è quello
con la plastica bianca poi ce ne montato
sormontare le ventole perché come ho
detto non è soltanto una teca di
prototipazione rapida per creare degli
oggetti di design ma anche degli oggetti
utili
la cosa bella delle stampa 3d e che sono
autori plicanti in cosa vuol dire che
giustamente potendo potendo replicare
potendo creare qualsiasi parte in
plastico in metallo si possono auto
ripiegare posso replicare i pezzi che la
compongono
ovviamente non la circuiteria ma posso
creare anche quasi totalmente tutta la
struttura e per questo da una sola
stampante possiamo averne 10 100 1000 e
questa tecnologia che si sta sviluppando
tantissimo negli ultimi anni sta
ricoprendo davvero tantissime
tantissime aree della nostra vita anche
se purtroppo è ancora poco conosciuta
grazie mille